tonight the golden knights continued the
fight against the canadians and the
stanley cup semifinals
puck dropped here just about 6 15. so
thanks for joining us i'm denise feldas
i'm kirsten joyce the series of course
tied at two games apiece
tonight it's game five at the fortress
that's where we find sports director
chris matthews
and he's got the very latest for us from
inside
well thank you very much guys yeah the
series tied two games apiece
so this is a huge one tonight game five
who can take that step closer to
reaching
the stanley cup final joining me now is
brian killingsworth who is the director
of marketing for the vegas gold knights
you guys always have cool stuff going on
what's going on again tonight
well we've got the battle towels again
we've got a suit of cards the zach white
cloud
is our battle towel for tonight and
we've got new playoff gear that we've
got throughout the playoffs that we're
let's look at that so right here is the
short sleeve hoodie
nice little workout hoodie with the
playoff gear right there okay
we've got uh the victory flamingo right
here so we've been waiting to unveil
this this is the victory
that looks pretty good now explain the
flamingo here that's pretty cool so it
started in year one
where uh some lucky fans actually throw
a flamingo on the ice after a win and so
we decided to commemorate that with this
shirt as well that looks really cool
what else you got
always cool stuff with the vegas golden
knights here yeah we got to be top-notch
in cutting edge so this is lululemon
it's a special line from lululemon that
we've got different gear
and so this is a nice little sweatshirt
we got really soft all these are
available at the armory
here at t-mobile arena going back to
this with you got what nick holden on
this one tonight what
explain what the the towels as opposed
to maybe pom poms and stuff
you know we like to keep it traditional
here and so this is a deck of cards zach
white cloud tonight and our great
sponsor silver state
and we've mixed it up with different
jersey colors all throughout the year
and different suits of cards so that
fans can collect the whole series
i said hold yeah zach white cloud here
tonight hey now what everybody always
kind of wants to know is who's going to
wind up the
the rally uh siren well we've had a lot
of luck with the raiders so we're
bringing out henry ruggs
henry ruggs has got the the first rally
siren and then we cap it off
with kelsey plum from the aces all right
good luck charms with the raiders and
the aces tonight brian
i appreciate you joining us tonight boy
go nights go right tonight all right so
game five big one tonight let's go
outside in the uh
toshiba plaza that was where kevin
martin is hanging out with lots of those
medieval maniacs
thanks chris we are getting closer and
closer to puck drop for game
five at t-mobile arena a lot of
excitement and
golden knights fans all over the place
not hard to find
them it was a nail biter in game four
the golden knights pulled it off they
now return home series tied 2-2
how excited are you for game five i
can't wait we're going up tonight and
then we're taking it game six we're good
i love the confidence and you guys are
heading in you've probably been to many
games what are you expecting the
atmosphere to be like in there for game
five tonight
pure electricity pure aggression
and pure power speed i
love it i love it and real quick can i
get a prediction give me a prediction
final score what are you thinking
oh 3-0 we got this we're a three-nothing
shutout okay
i like it can you guys give me a go
knights go to send me out
awesome reporting live at toshiba plaza
kevin martin
8 sports now